you were the anger translator for our
the real president with the actual real
theatrical President Barack Obama
character named Luther because many
people thought that President Obama was
a little button down and he would say
things that were a little
passive-aggressive or than you got to be
the angry I got to be the end I got to
be the emotion for him yes yes and what
this meant when you did this is that and
I want you to do this in several times
you got to perform with President Obama
erect as your comedy partner what was
that like it was it was really amazing
and it wasn't as surreal as you'd think
it was because we got to rehearse ahead
of time so I got to kind of get used to
him being there the craziest thing is
he's so tactile that he loves to like
told people and touch people and hug so
he walked in the door and pretty much
attacked me sorry Valerius there he is
my man never escaped murderers there is
so he gets right on top of me and I'm
going how many guns alright so but it
was it was a really wonderful experience
in heat and once again his timing is so
fantastic I was great comedy time really
I don't know that that those White House
Correspondents Dinner were fantastic in
the last eight years yeah it's fantastic
I did one I think like two years ago and
got to just sit there I went on after
him but just watch him and just you
sitting on your level well I gotta
follow that yes guys so he's at center a
time yeah so so you got to do that with
him and would he ever talk to you I mean
you ever get a sense of him just as a
normal guy complaining about his job
yeah actually during during the
rehearsal he was going through the
script beforehand that the bit he was
doing before I came on right and he was
literally going he's like Republicans
are gonna block the thing and do the
other thing and he's like this isn't
even a joke I mean look at this [ __ ]
oh it was like your dad okay grandpa
swearing like you're not allowed to
swear how you sad that you won't be able
to do that character anymore I am said
it was it was I think it was kind of a
moment in time type of thing and and I
don't see it going on unless I follow
him on the lecture circuit like a real
really weird creep yeah so what we'll
see and because I don't I don't see how
it can go further you don't see how
Trump does not need an anger translator
there's a lot of things Trump needs yeah
one is not an anger
[Applause]
you